not everything is great if you literally  slept with someone and then you felt bad  about it that doesn't mean that i was  great and so i just need to say that for  the women because y'all are saying that  everything is great and if it was why  didn't you report it to the cops and why  didn't you go to the hospital and why  didn't you get the pill so that you  could take care of that possible um i  don't know if i can say the a word on  here but why don't you do that no  because you actually are just dealing  with the emotions of the fact that you  didn't want to sleep with that person  and then you consented to it because you  were drunk and they were drunk and then  now y'all got to deal with it so no not  everything is great not everything is  essay and you need to just understand  that  maybe you made a bad decision and maybe  you got to deal with it